I'll be going red my name is pure bat
but it's the father the father you son
of a [ __ ] I know you're here somewhere
that [ __ ] piano girl is there
something here piano girls did you never
trust them alright let's [ __ ] am i doing
I have a crowbar but whoa
I'm sorry sorry game
alright alright alright don't worry
about it
wha what are you doing get off me bounce
okay oh cool
good thing I have a lantern because you
know did you just move on me [ __ ] no
all right let's investigate
ha-cha-cha what are you doing in here
protect doesn't catch up did you know it
was my favorite dish
come on a potato what is this the
placement potato this is not seem good
nah [ __ ] me I can't go there anyway
okay don't come here Jason skies this
year any potato can I call you a potato
puto no calm down
Jason sky your name is Katy Perry
all right fine Katy Perry what's all
that cracking I don't like this Perry
I'll cook you I'll come back later all
right
what more Keys now maybe nope I can't
pick these up I think maybe a four that
looks pretty pick up the ball fine what
sorry that's fine all right
what is up here can we go here whoa
it's just the [ __ ] battery room all
right we're going back okay we're not
going all right this ambience really
does a lot it's [ __ ] scary and the
sanity is not that good
Oh how'd it go I mean huh come on gimme
that nada nada nada nada that it what
the fauna what are you doing all right I
need to chill here a little bit actually
because my son it is so [ __ ] look
it's triple that what I have it's an
abortion so which really doesn't make
much sense but hey I'm just rolling with
it
thought I tried it out all right why the
hell did he go it's our room it's one of
these rooms
oh nothing garage girl kind of confused
we need this crowbar but I really don't
know why sorry sorry about I all right
it ed let's keep going up maybe here no
[Music]
well I don't like this corridor I really
don't like it
certainly room.we I can't go to this one
baby this isn't me it's the finest room
oh oh here it is are you kidding me
yes oh I was just about to cheat I mean
I never cheat but you know all right
Oh probably wallpaper all right let's
put down the light doesn't work that
it's not a problem
it sounded like someone is fapping in
the other room I don't like the sound of
fapping not into this game at least I
mean not in any scenario why do I keep
finding all of the new line in don't dis
da as mmm I don't know
hey don't kill me what are you trying to
hide who's popping what Jen's what are
you doing
Suzi yes [ __ ] off
ow stop jabs we can be friends all right
what do I got
hydro flue sills please all right [ __ ]
it
we'll take this and we'll put it on our
penis all right we'll have a bottle of
acid now I don't know why at least we
have the lantern dance what should I do
I don't know if hitting well you never
know take his bow Oh
dance it's you and me please don't tell
him I'm sorry for what I said before
what yes what are you doing in my face
you liked it I pee a little
ha chance Amos [ __ ] Jess don't you
dare do anything John stop hopping about
ok keep humping the mouse there's no
puede don't come in here don't come in
here don't come in here I can run I can
hide I will never sleep without Jen's
are you serious [ __ ] you no you know
what I don't give a [ __ ] that's how we
do it in here by time alright what do we
do with a bottle of acid that can be
used to corrode metal and other objects
well what objects Jesus call [ __ ]
let's not make him come here
I do not want him over here do your
thing breath did he go [ __ ] me
whoa hyah
no no
huh anyway ah I have a heartbeat sensor
should you stay seriously
my heart is [ __ ] good can you go away
please
all right we may depress we [ __ ]
Mayday
now where do we use this because I was
thinking I could use the crowbar I'm
like different objects and shapes maybe
on your little [ __ ]
what oh he's upstairs good alright still
scares me I don't like this breast
alright so where did we put the asset
I really don't [ __ ] up hmm
maybe no no it's too good to be true
oh yes
Jainism strikes twice do you see that
dog a Papa yes doggy yes yeah come on
faster hell yeah [ __ ] first the
door cuz you never know these days
wow what is happening all right Oh what
is up with this all right no no I
[ __ ] hate the gun girl I'm not gonna
lick your [ __ ] I got goose mugs oh good
I look like a hare [ __ ] Jesus guys I
hate the gun guys Cara and some boy
Oh danger let's lick this the electrical
fuse is activated route to the Clank all
right don't leave Xena
sounds like the starting of a heavy
metal concert all right what you better
leave the mansion as fast of all this
something hard is wrong with this maybe
you can escape through the basement wait
I thought I was in the basement no don't
come in here
Oh baby ah damn I was not ready for that
what the [ __ ] I think it was admissible
all right
the hell am I going let's go down the
beach
van [ __ ]
watch we're done it Stefano pair the
Oscar I know ok that's enough all right
baby you enjoy it
this guy come forth Jane I'll see you
next episode or whatever Nick
[Music]
they held a that what the hell are you
doing who the boy sucks the PI's gay